make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are here here's the thing
okay so King Thor is a monthly series
right it's a four issue series as far as
I'm aware but it's a monthly series so
the next one I want to say part three at
the time that we're recording this video
part three comes out on November 20th
and then I want to say part four comes
out towards the end of December like
December 18th or something along those
lines so we've got a little bit before
we get to the conclusion of this but
this story is amazing okay so if those
are guys who are unfamiliar this
basically includes Jason Aaron's run on
four right like King Thor is the end of
his run on four which I will I will
still say to this day and I've read
while Simon stands for this is the best
run on Thor that I think there's ever
been it's insanely good from like the
original god of thunder up to Jane
Foster Thor all the way through all-new
all-different marvel - the war of realms
all the way up until now it is fantastic
but it's amazing how good it is so what
this does and this is seem to kind of
explain here right it's been a while
since we recorded it since we did the
original for god of thunder now you guys
are welcome to go check that out if you
want like a really in-depth perspective
on what's going on but essentially this
is in the far flung future basically at
least at least it was until the end of
god of thunder all life on Earth had
been destroyed right anyway it was wiped
out by Loki Loki was the one who killed
everybody on earth all the superheroes
the whole nine yards earth was just like
this giant barren wasteland ah but even
with that being the case at the end of
Thor god of thunder Thor had basically
planted the seeds of life to be reborn
on earth right so life was basically
flourishing and it was coming back so on
and so forth as for the other realms
that are part of the Asgardian mythos
they're all basically dead Jotunheim and
and Muspelheim and all that the only one
that I think that has any real measure
of life in it is nifelheim and only
because of the realm of Hell with hell
are ruling over everything but even then
I don't think we have an answer on
what's going on with her as far as we're
aware pretty much everything in the
universe is dead well is it a point
where everything is beginning to come to
an end and so what this does is this
picks up at the library of worlds now
the library of worlds was this library
that Jason Aaron created whereby it had
all this information on gods right you
could go to this place and you could
basically research all these different
gods across the entirety of the universe
right and learn all about them and all
these different things but this place is
basically being investigated by the
daughters of Thor and the reason isn't
initially made clear instead as they're
making their way through it and as
they're looking through everything they
end up coming across Shadrach
drak he was he was one of the cooler
characters adjacent here and created
this is what I forgot if thunder was so
incredibly good Shadrach would he
originally appeared in forgot of thunder
he said he was like the god of music or
something along those lines but it
actually turned out he was the god of
bombs and the idea behind this was that
Gore that God butcher had basically been
seeking out a way to create this giant
God bomb tried to create this bomb that
could be thrown into the timestream and
then wipe out all God's in existence
from the very beginnings of the universe
all the way until it's end right because
he just he hated gods but he cursed gods
because he lives in an exceedingly harsh
environment and he believed the gods of
his world had turned their back on him
and that's the reason why he had lost
his wife and his his children and so on
and so forth was because he believed
that the God's and we just didn't care
him so we got on a crusade to kill all
the gods across the universe that's the
entire basis behind the Thor the god
butcher storyline it was absolutely
amazing
but Shadrach seems to have survived all
of this right he seems to have made it
all the way to the very end and when the
question is asked how it was and he
managed to pull this off the response is
that originally when you have the
librarian who was there basically taking
care of all these books all this
knowledge that have been gathered over
the eons all these stories that have
been told about all these exploits of
these gods that has always been in
existence that as they were all being
killed off by Thor of course those
stories have been told but as you got
towards the end of the timestream
eventually the library and basically
died of old age and as a result of that
Shadrach had taken over for him and
tried to keep the library together as
best he could but again you know you're
at the end of all things here and so
basically it's kind of a collapse of
everything kind of the end of everything
and that's the question that's asked by
by the daughters is we're here to seek
help you know to find something that can
help us for what's to come you know for
basically like like what's gonna happen
with the end of things now it's cool to
sort of see this play out because what
they kind of seem to be alluding to is
the idea of like Galactus with the
all-black necro soil right that's kind
of what we saw at the end of Thor god of
thunder is that Galactus had attained
the all black necro sword and then gone
forward is like you know Galactus the
the all black necro world eater whatever
it is you want to call it but he was
just like this super dark energy powered
cosmic being right that seemed to be the
case that was going on and that looks
like what it is that they're referring
to and this sense of like this is what's
to come you know it's all going to go to
pieces and they're trying to find help
with this and so what it does is it
switches over to basically the final
battle between Thor and Loki between old
King Thor and Loki and this is a battle
that's been a long time coming that's
kind of the cool things that that that
gets said here but what we end up
learning is that Loki is actually
attained the all black necro sword for
himself now this is what our explanation
of the all-black
Rosaura timeline begins to come into
play right because there's some things
about how Loki got this sword that we
need to cover right so the idea behind
this all-black necro sword really
originates with know the symbiote God
and that's why this is so cool right
because it's hisin everything that that
goes on that when the universe came into
existence prior to that you just kind of
had this giant expanse of emptiness when
the universe came into existence that
basically the celestial started creating
life and so on and so forth now
following the timeline of the Ultimates
insofar as al Uli's ultimate Avengers
storyline with Adam Brashear with a blue
Marvel and black panther all that kind
of stuff we could resume the war between
the the aspirants and the Celestials
broke out but regardless the
circumstance the creation of life in
what was previously this massive empty
void that was occupied by North was seen
as a kind of encroachment on Dan'l's
territory and as a result of that know
basically fashioned the all-black necro
sword as a weapon that can be used to
kill Celestials which he was initially
successful in doing but ultimately
defeated following that the sword of
null basically fell into the hands of
Gore the god butcher when gorg cursed
the gods and then two gods fell down to
his planet and so as a result of that
gore the god butcher took the sword and
then went on his campaign to kill all
these different gods across the universe
ultimately Gore was defeated by Thor
from three timelines from this future
version here and then the modern-day
Thor in the main Marvel Universe and in
Thor in the past from the main Marvel
Universe and so as a result to that
ultimately he was defeated that
basically led to the all-black necro
sword bonding itself to Galactus and
then Galactus going forward as as
basically the the butcher of world
following that and going into Thor issue
number 700 Galactus was confronted by
ego the Living Planet and ultimately the
necro sword the all-black bond itself to
eco who in turn consumed Galactus and
that basically led to Loki facing off
and really kind of challenging ego
during Thor vol 5 issue number 5 in
issue number 6
when Loki defeated ego and then took the
necro sword for himself and that's kind
of how you run into the situation where
Loki currently hasn't known and it's a
cool thing to see right because Loki
having this all-black he looks like Gore
but he also looks really really cool the
funny thing about this is that Thor
really begins to sort of consider the
fact that he cannot defeat Loki that
Loki can't really be defeated by King
Thor himself and in truth that's that's
a true statement right I mean Loki
wielding the all-black necro sword
there's no way the Thor can really beat
him and the reason why is because with
with the battle between the Oh Ford and
gore the god butcher it took three
Thor's in order to defeat
and ultimately you know it was being in
the right place at the right time right
where Thor was able to absorb the all
black into himself take two hammers and
then defeat the Figur that way but what
you're talking about here is where Gore
was basically a singular mortal being
who is bonded with immense power that
Loki is immortal right like he's
basically this this God more or less who
now has the power of the all black
there's no way the Thor can beat him and
Thor amuses about that right like one of
the things that he does is he actually
sends his hammer to the far side of a
star in order to bring it back while
it's on fire and because they're on a
world with with basically napalm for
water he ends up basically blowing the
world up right like using using his
hammer touching it down to the water and
then setting the world on fire setting
off like these massive nuclear
explosions at the same time that happens
shadrach recalls what it is that he's
Agana that he's actually a god of bombs
and ultimately ends up blowing up the
entire library of worlds and in the
process it seems like it although I
wouldn't swear to it but it seems like
the daughters of Thor are killed in the
process now I'm not gonna swear that's
the case and we're gonna have to wait
with issue number two to find out but
the cool thing is that during this
battle between Loki and Thor Loki is is
is quite handedly tearing Thor apart the
funny thing about this is that Thor
basically cast Loki into the Sun now
initially Jason Aaron kind of plays this
in in a scenario where it's like and now
Thor's won right it's almost kind of how
he plays it off until a floor basically
talks about how it doesn't really seem
like it would be enough and it wouldn't
right I mean yes like like the Sun is a
pretty huge thing in terms of like the
amount of energy it puts off the amount
of pressure you had in a start but it's
not enough to kill Loki not by a mile
especially with him using the the all
black and so coming out of this thing
ultimately the fight breaks out you know
yet again between Loki and forth and the
funny thing is they end up back on earth
right so what you end up having is
almost this identical scenario where you
end up having two gods who are fighting
each other they crash land on a planet
it's like the origin of gore the god
butcher and it's kind of a funny thing
because we're not really given the
perspective of the people on this world
right like whether or not life is harsh
it doesn't look like it there's trees or
there's grass and all that kind of stuff
so these people really see why they're
having more of a pretty basic lifestyle
as opposed to like an overly complicated
one or a very harsh one like what Gore
was going through but where Loki
basically says like this is the end like
you are going to die now and it's
actually in the process of getting ready
to kill for it suddenly Loki is stabbed
through the back and it's just like like
I'm always looking at this and I was
like I was like what in the heck is my
initial thought was Loki had lost his
sword and the sword came crashing back
down to earth and ultimately ended up
stabbing in the back felt like he was
stabbed in the back
on sword when it fell but then of course
loki falls down next to thwart and in a
man on this reminiscent decor the god
butcher and then these words come out of
nowhere and it's like two omnipotent
brothers fighting over nonsense this is
why i hate your kind this is why all
gods need to die and this is when we
basically end up finding out that these
words are emanating from the greatest
enemy that thor has ever faced yes
ladies and gentlemen gore the god
butcher has returned with that being
said guys we're gonna read this video to
an end if you are new here to comment
explain cliffhangers if you are new here
to come this explain make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]